geh mal nicht an mein Ei
ran das hat richtig weh
[Musik]
getan oh mein Gott dummer Alter guten
Morgen von meiner
Toilette kann mir irgendwer von euch
sagen ob man diese Instagram Notizen die
man über sein Nachrichten sieht
irgendwie deaktivieren kann oder
zumindest ausblenden oder so also sorry
an alle Leute den ich folge aber
überhaupt nicht was ihr gerade macht
oder was für ein Lied ihr euch gerade
anhört es geht ins Fitnessstudio meine
Damen und Herren und das natürlich
gemeinsam mit meinem Lieblingstrainer
mikrof hallo ich bin im Fernsehen wir
trainieren heute hier rechts von links
Entschuldigung wir trainieren heute
tatsächlich hier ist auch rechts
[Musik]
vud wir trainieren heute tatsächlich
pull Bizeps richtig ja das ist mach
einmal
Soundcheck ihr dürf nur 125 kg rein das
heißt Du darfst nicht
mitfahren hauptsache wir sind hier am
Fahrrad fahren und da vorne gibt's Leute
die einfach ein echten Job haben erstmal
hier schön mein lieblings youber
schauen ist auch egal ST auf de Flasche
animal drauf weil du ein Hund
[Musik]
bist ich Ken wirklich niemanden der ein
fC Köln Sticker auf seiner Kofferraum
hat aber keinen einzigen Spieler kennt
doch wen ich kenne ein Fußballspieler ja
wen Lionel
[Musik]
Messi das hier ist immer noch der beste
Sticker für Coach F von Luca der klebt
seit
wann halben Jahr oder irgende was
bedeutet diese warenleuchte dass dies
der Wagen sehr gut funktioniert und
trotzdem sehr gut
fährt das ist nur eine Warnung Bruder
das ist noch nicht kaputt das muss
bedken
ich k niemanden der 187 im Auto pumpt
aber dann so die Maus da vorne drin sitz
W D verarscht übrigens we aufen stehen
namens
[Gelächter]
coach.
nicht
ander schön dass du da bist ich bin
Coach
Mo
youbeet zugesandt und daher dachte ich
mir schnappen wir uns mal wieder
Katharina voll viele haben letztte mal
den Joke nicht verstanden das ist ein
Cutter deswegen Katharina ich hab mein
Humor nicht
verdient oh oh das ist der goldene play
bututton für meinen
zweitkanal
danke danke YouTube
[Musik]
und danke euch for real ich weiß ich bin
oft ironisch dumm und so aber das meine
ich gerade wirklich ernst eine oh guck
mal 1 Million Abonnenten auf dem
zweitkanal Kuss Leute wirklich danke
euch für den Support falls noch kein
Abonnent seid von Lu habt aber auch
eigentlich alles richtig gemacht so hier
wollte ich dann eigentlich ein coolen
shot machen wie Sandra und ich zum
Mittagessen gehen allerdings seht ihr
jetzt schon alles gut
wir mussten erstmal noch diesen Mann
hier vorbeilassen der mit seinen drei
Hunden spazieren war doch dann ging es
[Musik]
los
breaken mit meinen
[Gelächter]
Freunden WN man die
türuto
Klappe soll ich dir den B an dein Kopf
schmeißen oder hat Angst vor Insekten
und das ist wachungskamera Aufnahme wo
in deren Wohnung so ein krankes
insekachet g
[Musik]
reagiert wie heißt du auf Instagram ich
Heer okay alle
Folgen total toll sind jetzt hier in der
Box bei getspeed Mercedes AMG
Performance keine Ahnung auf jeden Fall
kommt jetzt gleich ein Fahrerwechsel der
Fabi unser Kollege fährt gerade der ist
wie vielter ist der zweiter warum ist er
nicht erster auf jeden Fall wird jetzt
hier gleich gewechselt weil die Fahrer
ja immer nur eine gewisse Zeit fahren
können bis sie dann irgendwie keine
Ahnung pissen müssen scheißen hallo mein
Name ist Christian von eiscam United B
ein Freund von Lasa
hi hi reicht langsam bei diesen
Aufnahmen war dann mein Mikrofon
irgendwie leer ist aber auch nicht
weiter schlimm denn ich stand eigentlich
nur im Weg rum wie hier beispielsweise
für den Tankwart hier für den Typen der
die Reifen wechselt und hier für den der
die Reifen wieder nach hinten bringt ich
bin einfach der beste vlogger
[Musik]
Deutschlands wie war's sehr
gut und wie viel da wur du Rennen läuft
noch denkst du wie lange noch noch so
anderthalb Stunden und danach gehst du
mit dir ich möchte ganz kurz klarstellen
dass ich an diesem Abend keinen einzigen
Tropfen Alkohol getrunken habe denn ich
befinde mich gerade im saber
Oktober ein Bier habe ich
[Musik]
vielleicht dieses Ding hier werde ich
nie verstehen wenn man seine Hand
runterhält ein Luft raus man muss seine
he genau da drunter halten genauso wie
es hier steht aber Dinge die man
erklären
muss dumm ich se gut aus der Typ da
hinten sitzt einfach aus wie Musial so
eine misch aus miala und
Bellingham mit den
[Musik]
Idioten ist geil ne kann schon die Kombi
süß ne meine Frau eine Sache die ich
extrem unsinnig find sind
autros warum sagen so viele Youtuber am
Ende ihrer Videos hey wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst ein Daumen hoch da
abonniert meinen Kanal Bruder wenn es
uns gefallen hat dann liken wir das
Video eh wenn wir mehr Videos sehen
wollen dann abonnieren wir deinen Kanal
die Sache ist allerdings dass hier auf
meinem Kanal fast 70% der Leute die
gerade zuschauen kein Abonnent sind und
das ist gut so das würde ich euch
nämlich auch nicht empfehlen dass ist
schwachsin meinen Kanal zu abonnieren
alles richtig
gemacht gute
[Musik]
Nacht
boй